il suffit de les apercevoir quelques
instants pour comprendre qu'ils vont
rapidement atteindre le statut de
vedette trois chatons lynx deux femelles
et un mâle qui explorent le tout nouvel
habitat le Biodôme de Montréal
vraiment très beau à voir alors c'est
toute une merveille de pouvoir les voir
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez vu les
petites robots oui les chatons sont nés
le premier mi dernier leur croissance
comme celle de tous les félins et
rapides après deux mois d'allaitement
ils étaient déjà solides sur leurs
pattes
puis il y a 10 jours ils ont commencé à
découvrir le monde extérieur celui du
Biodôme était très nombreux visiteurs
souvent on a l'impression quand
est assez rapidement là on voit les
attributs là qui fait que ça se
différencie donc les grosses pattes pour
marcher dans la neige les petits poils
sur les oreilles puis vraiment le
Lincent l'instinct sauvage comme
l'habitat des lynx c'est très réduit
l'équipe du bio dôme a développé des
outils pour encourager le développement
des chatons odeur goût obstacle physique
l'exercice est quotidien on vraiment les
pousser le sur des sens qui utiliserait
normalement pour les forcer à travailler
il y a pas de bol là ta nourriture faut
que tu travailles pour la voir puis même
si ça te prend la journée ça te prend la
journée mais il y a rien de gratuit
d'ici un an les chatons auront atteint
leur taille d'adultes soient entre 20 et
30 kilos il faudra alors les déménager
dans une institution qui partage la même
vision que Biodôme présenter des animaux
sauvages au grand public mais également
aux besoins assurer leur survie à long
terme les langues qui sont sous soin
humain peuvent servir de de population
d'assurance advenant que qui se passe
quelque chose en milieu naturel ou de
support aux populations en milieu
naturel si on avait besoin de
réintroduire des individus en nature et
pour ceux qui se demandent peut-être
quels sont les noms des trois petites
vedettes du Biodôme la réponse est
simple ici on veut vraiment
mon expérience comment forêt donc en
forêt les animaux en pas non on suit ce
même principe là au bidon
Radio-Canada Montréal